[Musik]
den aufschlag einer turbulenten masken
woche machen am sonntag kanzler olaf
scholz und sein vize robert habeck das
duo reist im regierungsflieger nach
kanada journalistentross inklusive doch
was fehlt und sorgt für mächtig ärger
keine maske wohin man sieht im
linienflieger gilt für otto
normalverbraucher nach wie vor die
masken pflicht beim regierungsflughafen
freiheit in diesem sommer regieren auf
höchster politischer ebene doppelmoral
und arroganz gemessen wird mit zweierlei
maß ist eben so könnte man das nicht
ändern gerechtigkeit schaffen könnte
[Musik]
doppelmoral und arroganz stadt klar
erkennbarer strategien in der deutschen
politik nicht nur im flieger auch in
bussen geht aktuell nichts ohne maske zu
spüren bekommen dass diese woche zwei
schüler sehen und zwölf jahre alt die
fliegen in der nähe von wismar
kurzerhand aus solch einem schulbus ihr
vergehen die maske sitzt nicht richtig
an dieser bushaltestelle müssen die
schüler aus gnade vor recht fehlanzeige
der vater eines jungen noch immer empört
in einem hoch
die regeln im schulbus strenger als im
regierungsflieger ist ebenso apropos
lauterbach an diesem mittwoch hat er
seinen großen auftritt
bundespressekonferenz
zusammen mit justizminister buschmann
verkündet er die neuen corona regeln für
herbst und winter ffp zwei masken
pflicht in fernzügen und ja auch in
flugzeugen masken und testpflicht in
kliniken und pflegeheimen und jedes
bundesland darf immer mal wieder für
sich selbst entscheiden erneut drohen
masken würmer und präge flut ist ebenso
in diesem sommer regieren auf höchster
politischer ebene doppelmoral und barock
gemessen wird mit zweierlei maß es ist
eben so herr scholz könnten sie da nicht
mal was machen ja
könnte
man bild chefredakteur claus strunz
doppelmoral und wenn wir dann nach
dieser doppelmoral mal kritisch
nachfragen bei der bundesregierung dann
wischt die diese fragen zur seite mit
arroganz
das ist jetzt heute so es wäre ja
wirklich zum lachen was wir da gesehen
haben und auch ein bisschen zum zum zum
schmunzeln aber es ist in der sache er
leider so traurig also wenn politik auf
bürger sorgen auf sorgen von menschen
die nicht mehr wissen wie sie ihre
rechnungen bezahlen sollen auf ängste
von eltern ob dieser ganze mit verlaub
scheiß in der schule wieder losgeht mit
den masken auf verwirrung bei
geschäftsleuten und gastronomen die
durch die hölle gegangen sind und jetzt
vor einer neuen hülle stehen vielleicht
dass das vielleicht ist ja das schlimme
vielleicht ja wer das anrichtet und sich
dann raus mogeln mit einem jahr könnte
ich oder so ist das jetzt halt das
fordert ein jahr da muss man sich ja
wirklich zusammenreißen um nicht karl
lauterbach beispielsweise entgegen zu
schleudern ich war aber zug ohne maske
so ist das halt mit einer
selbstverständlichen schutzbund arroganz
sozusagen den eigenen regel unsinn den
man an richtet dann auch noch sozusagen
wegzuwischen ist für mich ein weiterer
tiefpunkt der kommunikation von politik
über die sache reden wir gleich noch und
eine weitere einzahlung auf dieses
schreckliche konto der
politikverdrossenheit denn die frage
lautet der vertraut man diesen
herrschaften dass sie diese großen
fragen vor denen wir stehen diese große
krise wirklich lösen oder es ist wieder
so eine art psychotherapeutischer
stuhlkreis wohl jeder mal was sagen kann
und dann nimmt man den kleinsten
gemeinsamen nenner und richtet ein
riesiges deutschland aber das schlimme
ist ja auch die kommen ja damit durch
also und gibt es irgendwann mal
irgendeine konsequenz versorgt na ja sie
sind halt an der macht und die einzige
konsequenz die es geben kann ist sich
sozusagen darauf vorzubereiten dass über
sie abwählt bei der nächsten möglichkeit
ich glaube aber dass noch was anderes
zurzeit herausragen schlecht läuft noch
schlechter als es schon mal gelaufen ist
also karl lauterbach ist ja eigentlich
so etwas wie der bundes krankheits
minister ja also ständig geht es nur
wenn wir das nicht machen werden wieder
alle krank wenn wir das nicht machen
müssen wir alle sterben ich überziehe
ist jetzt genau wie er ja es ist eine
sozusagen
bestrafungs stadt belohnungs mentalität
eine angst macht mentalität ein
bevormunden statt vertrauen ich will ein
beispiel nehmen also man könnte ja zb
bei der klima frei wir sagen
wer dieses jahr in diesem winter nur die
hälfte seiner heizkosten hat kriegt vom
staat 100 euro wir sagen aber du du du
wenn du wieder zu viel heißt ja wenn du
über die regel werde dann kommt der
staat und brummte und ordnungsgeld auf
ja das ist genau der falsche ansatz wir
reden uns so massiv angeleitet von der
politik in eine krisenstimmung dass wir
in der krise womöglich untergehen das
zweite beispiel bevormunden statt
vertrauen im warum muss man sagen die
lichtreklame wird da abgestellt warum
überlässt man das nicht den leuten die
sie ja wahrscheinlich schlau genug mal
abstellen um weniger stromkosten zu
haben warum wieder zurück zur corona man
könnte auch und jetzt aber ich merke
jetzt schon diese passage wird sozusagen
heute den ganzen nachmittag und in der
ganzen folgezeit mehr um die ohren
fliegen von diesen ganzen corona panik
kann ja man könnte auch sagen ich
entscheide im zug selber hab ich eine
maske aufsetzen und wenn um mich um
lauter leute sind die husten und
schniefen dann setze ich sie mir auf
wenn aber da lauter kinder leiden sind
und dunkel gesunde 20-jährige die uno
spielen und lachen und nicht krank sind
dann setze ich sie nicht auf das könnte
zum beispiel entscheidend das wird mir
aber gar nicht ermöglicht weil es jetzt
wieder eine regel für alle mit einem
verstoß und einer bestrafung gibt also
wenn karl lauterbach der bundes
krankheits minister ist dann hat robert
habe gute chancen als bundes
bevormundung minister in die geschichte
einzugehen und olaf scholz der chef vom
ganzen übrigens kleiner hinweis der war
auch in der letzten regierung und ich
weiß nicht ewig regiert er schon er hat
vieles von dem von dem politiker jetzt
sagen gestern hab ich erst wieder ein
gehört deshalb als die
vorgängerregierung eingebrockt da kann
ich aber mal alles sozialdemokraten
daran erinnern da war die auch schon
dabei ihr habt uns eingebrockt und wenn
olaf scholz nicht aufpasst dann wird er
als der bundes bestrafungs kanzler in
die geschichte eingehen der ein land
sozusagen durch einen falschen ansatz
sein falsches paradigma in der politik
in eine situation gebracht hat die noch
schlechter ist als sie eigentlich hätte
sein müssen nochmal stichwort
doppelmoral beim hinflug von habeck nach
scholz vor immer habeck mit scholz nach
kanada wurde uns sehr erklärt na gut so
sind die regeln im regierungsflieger
masken freiheit aber die haben ja pcr
test gemacht rückflug von kanada nach
deutschland wieder masken frei diesmal
ohne pcr test unter regierungssprecher
hat das gestern auch ganz selbstbewusst
begründet das sei halt so was fällt dir
dazu ja gar nichts mehr weil wir dann
würde ich schon sagen okay freunde dann
lasst es aber bitte auch in allen
urlaubsflieger gelten ja wer mit einem
pcr test zum check-in kommt keine maske
vielleicht ist sogar die bedingung keine
maske dann sitzt man da ohne maske im
flieger da muss schon gleiches recht für
alle gelten oder gleiche sanktionen für
alle und ich bin mal sehr gespannt ob
nicht leute aus diesem regierungsflieger
jetzt krank werden wenn leute aus dem
regierungsflieger krank werden dann war
es fahrlässig sich so zu verhalten wenn
niemand krank wird dann wäre es eine
denksportaufgabe ob man ist nicht ganz
frei gibt masken freien allen fliegern
das ist das schöne in eine schöne frage
und wenn nicht irgendwelche
wissenschaftler wieder was neues
herausgefunden haben dass er ein paar
tagen wissen
und achten sehr genau darauf eigentlich
würde man sich ja schon fast darüber
freuen er klaute schön dass du da bist
wir wollen mit dir auch noch mal über
die bilder des tages sprechen wir
spielen sie mal ganz kurz ein du wirst
sie schon gesehen haben auch es geht
auch um olaf scholz der auf einen panzer
keller tja warum kommt noch eine leiter
hingestellt wir haben ein bisschen
geschmunzelt über diese bilder bei und
wir haben uns auch natürlich gefragt
hast du clever von seinem team zusagen
olaf macht das doch mal so oder hätte
besser unten bleiben sollen dann einfach
von unten schauen können müssen es sind
schon faszinierende bilder also weil man
fragt sich schon warum machte das
also will er jetzt eine deutliche geste
setzen der deutsche bundeskanzler in
einem panzer wie es sind auch sozusagen
wehrhaft um nicht zu sagen wir nehmen
ihm direkt auch an einem krieg teil will
er das symbolisieren das wäre ganz gegen
seine bisherige politische ausrichtung
oder will das mal ausprobieren das wert
zu kindisch aussehen tut es jedenfalls
so als hätte da nichts zu suchen und
jetzt muss man ein gedanken noch in
richtung ja wie soll man sagen ich will
ihnen jetzt nicht zu sehr beschützen
oder loben aber es ist schon ganz schön
mutig test zu machen denn stellt euch
einmal vor der rutschte aus mit seinen
lederschuhen und knallt hin oder fällt
runter das ist dann die metapher zu
seiner gesamten verteidigungspolitik um
nicht zu sagen zu seiner ganzen politik
aber das ist der punkt wenn wir auf
diese bilderschau und olaf scholz
klettert auf diesen panzer das
symbolisiert doch unser verhältnis das
verhältnis unserer politik hier in
deutschland zur armee zur bundestag ist
ein totales fremdeln ein jahr weiß ich
nicht so genau und wo muss ich mich denn
jetzt hinsetzen und alles
dann schaut wirklich gebannt hin dass
ich noch gestoßen blauen fleck am
oberschenkel
ich weiß nicht wen er sich da so sieht
ob es sich für ein großen kanzler hält
du selbst hast ja auch schon mal in
paragraph gedient ist es so einfacher
hoch zu kommen oder braucht es ja mein
persönliches schicksal war da durfte ich
nie hin ich war panzergrenadier ihr
kennt ja ich bin kein mensch ich bin
kein tier ich bin ein panzergrenadier
das sind die jungs und heute vermutlich
auch jungs und mädels gab es bei uns
noch nicht die jungs und mädels die
aussteigen aus einem panzer
und mit glück nebenher laufen können
oder sich irgendwo ein graben
deswegen sind mir panzer durchaus
vertraut in all ihrer wie soll ich sagen
wichtigkeiten schrecklichkeit damit
höher claus strunz bei uns panzer
experte einsatz des bundeskanzlers danke
danke
[Musik]